von der alpen idylle zum corona hotspot
das berchtesgadener land liegt
bundesweit auf platz eins mit einem
instituts wert von 236 ab heute 14 uhr
hielt dort die ausgangssperre
ausgangs beschränkungen im
berchtesgadener land die bayerische
touristenhochburg ist mit ihren
dramatischen incidents werten in den
letzten tagen deutschlandweit corona
spitzenreiter deshalb wurde vom
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten nun ein
lockdown verhängt ab dienstag 14 uhr
gelten nun neue corona maßnahmen
speziell die schulen müssen geschlossen
werden
die kindertageseinrichtungen müssen
leider geschlossen werden es ist so dass
die gastronomie ausschank oder
schankbetrieb letztlich eingestellt
werden muss das ist der normale betrieb
wir sind früher schon durchgeführt und
praktiziert wurde dass die gasthäuser
letztlich die verpflegung und kochen und
so weiter vornehmen werden können
es kann alles abgeholt werden ich glaube
dass dieser ganz wichtig ist dass man
jetzt auf 0 führt sondern dass man
wirklich nur die gastronomie am leben
erhält
wichtig ist auch natürlich der tourismus
bei uns im berchtesgadener land
der massive einschränkungen hat und vor
allen dingen auch die wirtschaft die
jetzt hat die nächsten 14 tage jetzt ich
sehr eingeschränktes wegen der maßnahmen
herrscht in der gastronomie und
tourismus branche große unsicherheit
also ich habe momentan angst vor keiner
reaktion wenn die haben leute zu hause
bleiben sollen nicht in urlaub fahren
sollen
wir sind eine urlaubsregion dann müssen
wir in irgendeiner form unterstützt
werden
auch touristen aus anderen bundesländern
sind ebenfalls unsicher wie und ob ihr
urlaub weiter geht vorzeitig abreisen
ist eigentlich nicht unser ziel weil uns
die bilder und das panorama hier schon
soweit beeindruckt haben das war schon
ganz gern die woche auch nutzen würden
um noch etwas zu unternehmen
aber man wird sehen was noch möglich ist
die menschen dürfen im gesamten
landkreis die eigene wohnung nur noch
aus triftigen gründen verlassen die
beschränkungen gelten vorerst für 14
tage
luisa volkhausen ist für uns im
berchtesgadener land hallo luisa sag uns
wie geht es den menschen in deutschlands
corona hotspot nummer eins die menschen
geht es aktuell noch ganz gut also noch
ist ja auch eigentlich sehr
normalbetriebs ab 14 uhr gelten die
neuen regeln
heute früh haben wir auch leute
beobachtet die sich noch mal einen
kaffee getroffen haben danach gesagt
haben wir ja umsetzen und geht es ja
nicht mehr
aber warum geht ihr verständnis da also
mal nimmt gefasst und mit dem vernünftig
gefasst entgegen er 14 uhr kommt es zum
locker und das bedeutet auch kitas und
schulen machen wieder dicht wie sie das
aufgenommen
[Applaus]
aktuell laufen die schulen nach erst elf
anfangen heute morgen ihren tieren dann
auch in die schule gebracht sich zu sagt
also natürlich eigentlich war die große
hoffnung dass zu vermeiden
jetzt kommt es dazu man muss es
hinnehmen das infektionsgeschehen ist
normal ära drastisch dass es auch dazu
kommen muss gibt es denn inzwischen
weitere erkenntnisse darüber was die
zahlen im berchtesgadener land so nach
oben treiben
dies ist ja immer wieder die rede von
einer molkerei party was kannst du uns
dazu berichten ist alles unklar also
eine spur führt hier nach dallas fliegen
hier soll es eine schießerei gegeben
haben befindet weshalb hier gezeigt hat
so eine mitteilung heraus in jedem am
samstag haben sich hier wohl in verlag
in karachi sabah eigentlich trotzdem
laufen heute mehr als 100 leute noch
nach schwersten getroffen und gefeiert
und den zug kommen dass die region
natürlich an die grenzen gehen sind in
der nähe zu österreich
und wenn wir einmal schauen sieben
kilometern bis nach salzburg
also es ist eine grenzregion es ist eine
tourismusregion viele touristen sind in
der stadt es mischt sich einfach viel da
kommt einiges zusammen aber konkrete
ursachen gibt es aktuell noch nicht die
werden mit spannung erwartet heute um 15
uhr ist eine pressekonferenz angekündigt
wir hoffen darauf in ihre erkenntnisse
luisa vielen herzlichen dank ins
berchtesgadener land wir sind bild und
wie ihr liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier und vergiss bitte nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren